so let me ask you a question what do you
think he did wrong
he's four years ago he's four years as a
president he knows that guy is there the
other guy is there he knows that this
been around for so many years you know
too many battles first okay like he he
needed to be more
strategically uh a kind of person he
fought too many battles the media the
whole media was against him with fake
narratives he knew that going in he knew
that but he he wasn't able to to ride
this the smoothly like he misused social
media with the guarding elected no I
think I think first of all during the
pandemics he could he could uh show a
different Behavior I I think so that was
one mistake not in terms of policies in
terms of policies it was just like
around DeSantis Fighting For Freedom
against this whole craziness uh uh
around the world but uh do you know
about the Brazil it reinstituted masks
on airplanes yesterday just just now
what just now
yeah it's like what I read this and I
was just as surprised as you it's like
what for what I woke up with this news
there's they're different rules and I'm
gonna I'm gonna bring it right there
just two months after a lifting uh a
long-standing mass mandate for airports
and aircraft Brazil has reinstated the
policy but will not go as far as a ban
in Flight meal service again Brazil's
health authority on Visa announced the
changes this week and the Mandate will
go into effect on Friday November 25th
you got to be kidding me I don't make
things up I know I know people that are
watching here like this this guy is full
of he's making things up and not nothing
that I'm talking everything is made up
everything's true well you have your own
research problems with FDA you know Dr
faulty but in Brazil everything is worse
so I think he could like show a
different behavior for especially for
the uh the people that like the the stat
Aesthetics point of life like I need
this guy cares about me he's he's saying
nice things and bolsonaro is not like
this as we mentioned he's like a what
you get is what you pay for but uh
people don't like it some some people
especially in the he's not a stranger
he's not a strategist and and to to
quote we mentioned a guy here called
Professor olavu Jaco Cavallo he's uh
he's he Rodrigo mentioned him he's uh
probably the most important thinker in
Brazil and what he used to say he before
he passed away he recently passed away a
few months ago he used to say that
bolsonaro's election was a miracle to
Brazilian society and it was it was just
a miracle uh and he the the main idea is
the same as the Breitbart Doctrine the
politics is Downstream from culture and
that's that's the reason bolsonaro was a
miracle because the code neutral system
in Brazil is to
embedded by the left
so the the mistake that value believed
that bolsonaro did is that once he took
office he thought he'd he could govern
with all the structure uh of of the
establishment and still be able to
govern and and and he he needed to
change Central points in the society so
he would be able to govern I have a
personal it's it's an interesting point
of view but it's easier said than done
it is but I have a more practical point
of view I think and do you really
believe that he went in thinking like
that that he was going to be able to
change the attitudes a lot of structure
I know for so many years or just being
naive is not what he was of course he
was naive he was never in office and I
think he made a serious mistake because
politics in Brazil is much easier than
politics in the US in a sense let me
explain why if you're a Republican
president and you get elected if you
have the majority in the house or the
Senate you'll be able to approve your
and pass your bills that's that's said
no Democrat will vote for you most of
the times mentioning is an exception
most of the times no Democrat will vote
with a Republican and most of the times
Republicans removal will won't vote with
them Democrat in Brazil the system's 31
parties so and and the they're very
they're not ideological Congress members
are not ideological as they are in the
U.S so you can pretty much buy them I'm
not talking about bribe just to be clear
you you can buy their favors just with
political support you know it's crazy
you're saying this I'm at Harvard at an
executive program for three weeks and it
is the face of the class where
everybody's open dialogue they're
talking with each other there's 144 of
us from 60 plus countries and one of the
guys says you know I have a business we
had 25 percent of market share we were
doing great but a new business has come
up and it's taken six percent away from
me and it's really become a pain and
about for us it's annoying how how do
you guys handle this from from different
parts of the country
one of the guys he says uh well it's
very easy who's running for office and
he says what do you mean he says well in
Brazil what we do is you just look for
who's running for office that can help
pass some laws you give them some cash
and when they go in if they need a favor
they're going to pay their favor for you
create new regulations to her and the
way he said it he didn't have a smile on
his face he said it as if it's written
in business books that this is how you
put out a small business you know it was
very much of a matter of fact a way of
communicating so what all the craziness
taking place I believe future looks
right if you believe future looks bright
get your latest Future looks bright hat
of valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red are black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people wore it in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hats best during
times like this because ain't nobody
saying future looks spread toward your
future looks bright hat click over here
and to watch the entire podcast click
here take care everybody
[Music]